Supreme Court to decide if IRS can
secretly obtain bank records okay this
is CPA practice advisor again this is
not Congress this is Supreme Court to
decide if IRS can secretly obtain bank
records
set to decide uh Paul Sally versus Iris
whatever the IRS uh whether the IRS can
obtain bank records from taxpayers
relatives without notice to help the
agency tax collection agencies tax
collection efforts and his decision is
expected early this summer the case
raises questions about taxpayer privacy
in IRS Authority amid the agency's 80
billion dollar on funding over the next
decade and I can continue in this case
Remo Porcelli owed more than two million
dollars in taxes to the IRS and the
agency issued summons uh to his wife's
bank and two other Banks where Paul
selly's Law Firm had accounts without
notifying his wife or firmed that the
IRS was trying to obtain the banking
information his wife
and the law firm argued that the IRS
should have should have to notify them
if they're going to send a summons for
their information for the banks the
point here is they're more and more and
more figuring out ways to control the
decisions people are making and the way
they sell it is in the following way
saying look
you to the average person do you want to
see these guys that are money laundering
through Bitcoin do you know what's
happening with all the pedophilia the
fear of all the things that Bitcoin and
crypto is used for this is one way for
us to prevent from illegal purchase of
weapons or money you know all money
laundering all the this is why we need a
cbdc because we can catch the criminals
easier if we have that and to the
average person who's only got six
thousand dollars in the bank and it's
got a regular job let's just say it's a
regular person says you know what that
does make sense these rich people have
been laundering money for such a long
time and it's about time we find out
what they're doing and a cbdc is
something we should do
being too confident kind of gives those
guys strength because they can play
their manipulative games until
eventually one day you're waking up
saying now we do have cbdc well I
mean I I agree with you if you're a
voter you ought to not it should be an
acid test I don't think anybody should
vote for a politician in favor of a cbdc
I mean it's this is the struggle uh you
know control versus Freedom that's as
old as time right in every society and
you know in the human in the history of
the human race every society there's
always people that want to impose
control on the people and there's
another group that want freedom I've
been I've been reading conceived in
Liberty which is Murray rothbard's
history of the American colonies before
the Revolutionary War
and it's hundreds of chapters Non-Stop
struggle someone wants to control a
colony they want to tell you what to
think they want to tell you you know
what you know who God is they want to
Define religion they want to impose
taxes they want to seize your property
they want to tax your property they want
to impose monopolies and then there's
another group fighting for freedom and
and it was going on for hundreds of
years before the Revolutionary War I
mean there were monopolies in New York
on who could bake you know they there
were tariffs on using the Hudson River
to go up and down the river there were
monopolies on who could trade with the
Indians they would give you land they
would steal your land they would tax the
land people wouldn't pay the tax there
were rebellions it's hundreds and
hundreds of struggles so it's been going
on before the Revolution it's going on
in every country in the world
today it's certainly going on and and if
you have any political power I think the
best way to use it is to support those
that trust people are in favor of
freedom because there's there tends to
be or seems to be this never-ending
tendency of governmental organizations
to get stronger and as they get stronger
they raise taxes they funnel the taxes
into the police state and the control
State and pretty soon it's illegal to
bake bread it's illegal to row up a
river it's illegal to cross the river
it's you know if you have land you have
to pay tax if you pay tax it has to
double
if it you know the taxes were used it
used to be we paid tax to pay ministers
to to to preach religious beliefs that
you disagreed with and if you you know
if you actually laughed or kissed your
wife on a Sunday they whipped you you
know it finds you and STEEZ your
property because you were disrespectful
to the almighty Lord and and I I'd like
to say it was uh it was unique and a
one-time thing but
it wasn't it's it's kind of the history
of humanity so it's going on today it's
it's reprehensible
and you can't see politicians that will
articulate that that message that the
people cannot be trusted and the
government needs to control everything
luckily we're in Florida where we where
we have a number of politicians that
believe differently
I'm hopeful that uh that we'll see a
backlash
to the control Tendencies and the
political sphere that have have
manifested themselves of the past few
years
and uh cbdc is just one of those
touchstones it's not the only one it
won't be the last one it wasn't the
first one so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign